>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, D.C.
>> Jennifer Harbster:
Good morning, afternoon,
11:30 is always afternoon, morning.
My name is Jennifer Harbster.
I am a Research and Reference
Specialist here at the Library
of Congress for the Science,
Technology and Business Division.
And I'd like to welcome
you to today's program,
Icy Volcanism in the
Outer Solar System.
This program is part of a 2015
series of lectures that's presented
through a partnership
between our division
and NASA's Goddard
Space Flight Center.
And I am very happy to report
that this is the 9th year
that the library has been
partnering with Goddard.
It is my pleasure to introduce
today's speaker, Dr. Lynnae Quick,
who is a Research Scientist
at Goddard's Planetary
Geodynamics Laboratory.
Dr. Quick received her
undergraduate degree in Physics
at North Carolina Agriculture
and Technical State University,
a Master's Degree in Physics at
Catholic University and a Masters
and a Doctorate, way to go, in Earth
and Planetary Sciences
at Johns Hopkins.
In addition to her work at
Goddard, Dr. Quick does outreach
to inspire girls into STEM careers.
She has been featured on the
Women and Planetary Science Blog,
which I have to plug for the library
because we are archiving the Women
in Planetary Science Blog
for our web archive project,
and she's also been involved
with the Carnegie Science Center
STEM Initiative called CanTEEN
Program that inspires
girls into Science careers.
As you will discover, Dr.
Quick has a really exciting
and I think dreamy job
that includes volcanoes,
icy moons in distant worlds.
She uses analytical methods to model
volcanic and cryovolcanic processes
on the terrestrial planets and the
moons of the outer solar system
with a particular emphasis
on Jupiter's moon, Europa.
Her other research projects
focus on Venus volcanism,
stability of a subsurface ocean
on Triton and that's Triton,
which is Neptune's moon, not
Titan which is Saturn's moon,
and the Europa imaging system.
So let's get to learning about icy
volcanoes in the outer solar system
and join me in welcoming Dr. Lynnae
Quick to Library of Congress.
[applause]
>> Lynnae Quick: Ok good morning.
I'm very happy to be here.
I'm used to walking
around a little bit
as I'm talking so please
bear with me.
So this is, thank you so
much for the introduction,
and so this is work that I've done
in collaboration with Lori Glaze
at NASA Goddard, Steve Baloga at
Proxemy Research and Bruce Marsh
at Johns Hopkins University.
And so you can see here,
to my right, your left,
so this is an artist
conception of an icy volcano
or of a cryovolcano
erupting on an icy moon.
And then next to it we see a
picture of Jupiter's moon, Europa,
which I have to say is my favorite
moon in the outer solar systems
and we'll talk about this.
Before we go there, these
pictures were floating
around Facebook actually last
week and I got very excited,
these are two images from the
Agricultural and Mechanical College
in Greensboro, North Carolina,
now North Carolina Agricultural
and Technical and State
University in 1899.
And so this is the school where I
received my Bachelor's Degree from.
And then you see one image
students in a biological laboratory.
And as our model, the model
of our school that goes
with our seal, is Minds and Hands.
It's an agricultural
school so you know you have
to teach them something that has
to do with agriculture and farming.
So there they are in their Sunday
best learning how to churn butter.
And this young lady here looks
like she could not, you know,
she looks like she could
not be any less happy
in her Sunday best learning
how to churn butter.
When I was at A&T we still
had biological laboratory.
We have a farm, nice cows and
pigs and all of those things
but I can say I never took
a butter churning class.
[laughter] So she's probably,
hopefully she's thinking
about planets.
So again these images are ones
that you all have in the Library
of Congress and I'll
was glad to see them.
I'm sure that they will
be glad that I'm here.
So let's get into talking
about cryovolcanism.
So here's an outline of my talk.
You're going to see that there are
lots of nice pretty pictures here.
This again is an artist
conception of a surface
of an icy body in the solar system.
First I'm going to talk about
volcanism in our solar system,
what are the different types.
Give you an introduction
to cryovolcanism.
What is it?
Where do we find it?
Then we'll talk about Europa's
physical properties and evidence
for cryovolcanism there
or icy volcanism.
We'll talk about the
composition of these lavas.
I'll talk briefly about a
model that I've developed
with some of my colleagues.
We'll talk about the
implications of that model.
Then we'll touch on
NASA's Europa mission.
That's very exciting.
And then just leave you
with a few lasting words
on the importance of icy moons.
So there's the outline.
So let's talk about the types of
volcanism in our solar system.
What you all are used to, what we
see on earth is Silicic Volcanism
and again that's volcanism
that we see on the earth.
It's happened on earth's moon,
on planet Mars, the planet Venus,
also on Jupiter's moon, Io,
there's lots of silicic
volcanism happening even now.
And so this is where the lava
or the magma is molten rock.
And so I'm going to use lava and
magma interchangeably so both
of them are the same material.
It's just magma is this molten
rock when it's in the subsurface.
After it erupts onto the surface
that's lava, same material.
And so then we have silicic
volcanism, which is what we're used
to on earth and other terrestrial
bodies, and cryovolcanism
which is what I'm going to talk
about today and this occurs
on the icy moons of
Saturn and Jupiter.
It may occur on some of the Kuiper
belt objects like Pluto and Charon
and possibly on hydrous asteroids
like the asteroids ceres and again,
cryolava, or cryomagma, I'll
be using that interchangeably.
And so usually these are just
fluids that are aqueous solutions.
Can be pure water.
Can have water mixed with salts,
mineral acids, ice crystals,
gas bubbles, water vapors,
carbon dioxide, things like that
so we'll talk about that.
So let's back up a
little bit and talk
about silicic volcanism
just for one more slide.
There are two types of lava that
we're familiar with on earth.
There's the mafic lava which
is rich in iron and magnesium.
It has an eruption temperature
greater than 900 degrees Celsius.
And this type of lava,
the salt is mafic lava
and if you've ever seen any
eruptions in Hawaii or pictures
of eruptions in Hawaii, you know
that this type of lava
is very quiet.
It's very effusive.
It likes to erupt and just
quietly flow along the ground.
There's no explosive eruption.
There's not much gas or much
volatiles in these eruptions.
And then we have felsic lavas.
And these lavas, such
as rhyolite and dacite,
they're rich in aluminum,
potassium and other elements.
They have slightly smaller eruption
temperature than mafic lava.
And they're full of
gases and volatiles.
And these are very high
viscosity explosive eruptions.
We see here on this slide, Krakatoa
in Indonesia which is erupting.
There's a lot of felsic lava here.
If you think about Mt. St. Helens,
that's a lot of felsic lava.
So mafic lava, quiet, effusive,
flowing, gentle, everything is fine.
Felsic lava you want to run.
It's explosive.
It's very violent.
And so when we think about
cryovolcanism we also have this kind
of effusive aqueous lava
that just flows nicely
and we also have explosive
cryovolcanism that occurs.
And so explosive cryovolcanism
is kind of what you see
on this artist conception.
It's geyser like eruptions
where you have ice particles,
water vaper, maybe carbon dioxide.
And again when I say ice particles
a lot of times it's water ice.
And as you move out further
and further and further
into the outer solar system you
might have nitrogen ice just
erupting very violently.
Think about old faithful,
old faithful in Yellow Stone,
but very big and very cold.
And so you also have
effusive eruptions
which again are just these fluids.
You may have ammonia as
a liquid once you get
out to the outer solar
system because it's so cold
when it's flowing onto to the
surface very acquiescently.
And so one thing to keep in mind is
that these eruptions are occurring
on bodies that are extremely frigid.
So their surface temperatures
are between negative 233
and negative 173 degrees Celsius.
So these are cold moons
and cold objects.
And if you think about, at that
temperature, ice is so cold
that it behaves the way
bedrock behaves on earth.
So there're really some interesting
stuff that happens there.
And so you can see that the maximum
eruption temperature of a cryolava,
you see here, is 0 degrees Celsius.
Here that's pretty cold, water
is, you know, it's freezing.
Out there that's hot.
It's very, very hot.
And so we've already talked about
where it occurs and I'll talk
about some of these bodies.
And one thing to think
about when we're talking
about cryovolcanism is you
can't always compare apples
to apples with volcanism on earth.
Cryovolcanism in some
sense is a misnomer.
Now I'll tell you why, so
we see all these images.
I don't know can you
all see the little arrow
from my cursor, yes or no?
It doesn't look like people can.
Ok, alright, so we have on the top
left we have an infusive eruption.
This is the quiet eruption.
The basaltic lava erupting
from Mauna Loa in Hawaii.
Then beside that we have Mt. St.
Helens, an explosive eruption.
Then on the bottom,
the very first picture
to your left is a fissure eruption
and this is also in Hawaii.
And so these first three images
that I've pointed you to,
nobody would say these are
not volcanic processes.
You have volcanism going on.
It's clear these are
volcanic processes.
But if you look at the kind of
yellow, tannish figure on the bottom
in the center this is a fumarole
where we have just steam coming
up from earth's surface and
then here's Old Faithful Geyser.
So nobody on earth would
say that this fumarole
and this geyser is
a volcano erupting.
But because of these, when we get
out into the outer solar system,
all of these processes on this slide
would be considered cryovolcanism
simply because of the
materials that these moons
or these bayous are made of.
Again, they're made of ice.
They're made of water.
They're made of carbon dioxide.
So any venting that you see form
the surface, whether it looks
like a geyser, whether it looks
like something that's erupting
from an icy volcano, we
call that cryovolcanism.
So we've talked about
cryovolcanism, the differences
between cryovolcanism and
just the silicic volcanism
that we see on earth.
So what was our first,
first look at cryovolcanism
in the outer solar system?
Well our first look was when Voyager
2 flew by Neptune's moon, Triton,
this is the largest moon of Neptune
and you see Triton at the top here.
I will say Triton is a sphere.
The reason that it looks like
this is because the camera,
when it took a picture
on the spacecraft,
was not able to get a lot
of the moon hemisphere
but I promise you it's
not cut off like that.
[laughter] I have to say that
I don't want anybody to think,
you know, it's funky looking
but it's actually a sphere.
And I like Triton.
I have to say when I was
much younger it was one
of my favorite moons because
it's actually tinted pink
and I love pink.
So we see that we have these, if you
look at the bottom going from left
to right, we see these wall
planes units in the first image
on your left and the
image in the middle.
This is the exact same surface
just from two different viewpoints.
And what it looks like, these
depressions are about 200 kilometers
across and they're
depressions and we believe
that ammonia lava's flowed into
these depressions and filled these
up and kind of made
a smooth surface.
The surface of Triton is
negative 200 degrees Celsius
so having liquid ammonia
there to flow can happen.
And if you look at the bottom,
the south pole of Triton here,
and then you look at the
image right below that,
you can see these dark streaks.
These are actually nitrogen geysers.
And the Voyager team was so
excited when they first saw these
so they're similar to Old
Faithful but erupting again cold.
They're 8 kilometers
above the surface.
And so it's pretty cool.
That was our first
look at cryovolcanism
and so everybody was really excited.
After these images were taken
people started looking at images
from other moons that the
Voyager spacecraft had looked at.
If you remember Voyager 1 and
Voyager 2 did kind of a grand tour
of the outer solar system
and took these images
of several different moons.
And so anywhere that there
was a smooth surface,
people thought oh my gosh, here's
an icy moon, don't see craters.
There's a smooth surface.
We don't see many depressions.
There has to be cryovolcanism
everywhere.
And so people were excited.
People looked more at those images.
The Galileo Spacecraft
went to the Jupiter system.
It was great.
And we found out after a couple of
years that cryovolcanism was not
as widespread as people had assumed
and that was because we were looking
at low resolution images
at the time.
And so as technology got better
and we had more missions then we
sent Cassini to the Saturn system
to look at Enceladus and
this is Enceladus here.
Enceladus is a cute little moon
and again the image is cut off,
one side of it is in the shadow, but
I promise you it is also a sphere.
And so it's a moon of Saturn.
It's a little warmer than Triton,
maybe 198 degrees Celsius
on the surface.
And we saw these spectacular
things when we looked at it.
We saw these geysers
erupting from the South Pole.
And these geysers are
mostly water ice.
There's some ammonia in there.
There's evidence for
rocky particles and salts.
And these geysers are, they
extend way out into space
to 500 kilometers off the
surface of tiny Enceladus.
And this is really crazy
because Enceladus is a moon
that has a radius of 252 kilometers
which means it's about the size,
it has a radius about
the size of Great Britain
so it's very, very small.
But you have all of this going on.
And if you look at the
bottom of this image
of Enceladus you should
see these kind of bluish,
in the South Pole you see
kind of these bluish lines.
We call those the tiger
stripes and that's
where these geysers are coming from.
And so it's really exciting.
We've also learned that these
geysers actually feed ice
to Saturn's E ring, to
one of Saturn's rings
so these particles
are really moving.
So that's great.
We've seen Triton.
We've seen Enceladus.
What else?
Well then there's Titan and Titan
is not to be confused with Triton.
[laughter] Of course.
And so Titan is Saturn's
largest moon.
It's the only moon
in our solar system
with an appreciable atmosphere.
It's very dynamic.
There's lots of cool
things going on there.
And so there's been kind
of speculative evidence
for cryovolcanism on Titan.
If we look at the first image
at the bottom to your left,
Ganesa Macula is the, there
are three images, well,
yeah three images so the first one
to your left you see Ganesa Macula.
And people got real excited when
we first took these radar images
and people thought, oh my gosh,
here is an icy volcanic dome
or cryovolcanic dome on
the surface of Titan.
And the reason being is because if
you look to the image of the right
of that, the image to the right
of that is the Rusalka dome
and that is a volcanic dome
made by very viscus lavas
on the surface of the planet Venus.
And people thought oh my
gosh, they look just alike
and they're even arrows
here on Ganesa Macula
on Titan showing what we thought
were cryolava flows erupting
from the top of that circular
feature which we thought was a vent.
And so people were very
excited about that.
Then Cassini took more
images and we found
out the Ganesa Macula is
not a cryovolcanic dome.
It's actually a feature
that's caused by tectonics.
It looks like this because
we have different movements
in the crust and in the lithosphere.
When you take images from different
angles you're actually able to see
that this is not cryovolcanic
feature at all.
So we thought oh, that's really sad.
No cryovolcanism on Titan.
And so then in 2010 and 2013 we
took some images of this region
on the surface Sotra Facula.
And you know it appears
bright in radar images.
It has irregular terrain,
which we now believe
that Sotra Facula is a cryovolcano.
And some of these white
features that you see,
this is to your far
right, are cryolava flows.
So that's great.
We think there's cryovolcanism
on Titan.
We think Sotra Facula is it.
People are still studying that.
One thing that I will
say is Titan has a very,
since it has such a thick, dense
atmosphere we wouldn't expect
to see anything explosive.
No geysers.
We would expect to see just
these thick viscus lava's
that meander across the surface.
So that's great.
We've talked about
Triton, Enceladus, Titan.
What about Kuiper Belt Objects?
And Pluto, poor little demoted
Pluto, which was a planet when I was
in elementary school, but
it's, you know, new horizons.
I don't know if you all heard about
the new horizons mission that's run
out of Johns Hopkins Applied
Physics laboratory in NASA.
And so we're getting back images
from new horizons as we speak
and they're still downloading data.
They're still analyzing it.
And so this is a true
color image of Pluto now.
That heart shaped region is Tombaugh
Regio named after Clyde Tombaugh
who first discovered Pluto.
And something that's
really, really interesting,
if we look at the picture, start
looking at the picture to the right,
if we zoom in on Tombaugh
Regio we see that there's a lot
of smooth surfaces and
we did not expect that.
We expected there to be a lot
of impact craters and lots
of depressions so we didn't
expect that smooth surface.
And it's been theorized that the
smooth surface may either be ice,
just ice flowing across the
surface just meandering.
Or the project Scientist
for new horizons during the
press conference said something
that made me very happy.
He said cryovolcanism,
maybe geysers.
We're still getting in data.
And so if we look at this picture
to the bottom left you see these
mountains, these little mountains
and wrinkles and bumps
and uplifts and in
between them the surface
is very smooth.
So that could be cryolava flows.
And I will say that before new
horizons reached Pluto we did have a
workshop where we talked about what
we thought we might see on Pluto.
And Pluto, it was thought,
to be very similar
to Neptune's moon Triton where
we first saw cryovolcanism.
So a lot of the theories said there
would be cryovolcanism on Pluto
so we see some surfaces that
makes us happy but we're going
to have to wait a little bit.
So then there's Pluto's moon Charon.
And Charon is much more geologically
complex than we thought it would be.
And this again is a new
image from New Horizons.
And one interesting thing about
Pluto is, I'm sorry, about Charon,
at other Kuiper Belt
items such as Quaoar,
I don't know if you
all have heard of that,
is that telescopic observations from
earth reveal there's crystalline ice
on the surfaces of these bodies.
Why do we care that
there's crystalline ice?
Well these bodies don't have
appreciable atmospheres.
And so any ice that's on the surface
of these bodies we would
think it would be amorphous
and by crystalline amorphous,
crystalline is just you have ice
and all the molecules and atoms
are in this nice ordered structure,
amorphous ice is when
it becomes disordered.
So we expect to see disordered
amorphous ice on the surface
of these moons, I'm sorry, on
the surface of these bodies.
And so telescopic observation shows
that there's been crystalline
ice on these bodies.
Crystalline ice can't stay on these
bodies for very long periods of time
because they have no atmosphere,
they're hit with different,
you know, different objects, comets,
asteroids, even some of, you know,
some particles from the
sun streaming way out.
So any time you have crystalline
ice on the surface of a body
with no atmosphere that's
this far out, that is a sign
that something has replenished
the ice on the surface
and brought something
new from the subsurface.
So that was taken to be a sign of
possible cryovolcanism on Charon
and other Quaoar objects.
Again, this third bullet point
says New Horizon's data is still
coming in.
And so we'll, hopefully
they'll find something.
That will make me very happy.
And then now we're looking
at water-rich asteroids
so this is the asteroid,
Ceres is the largest asteroid
in our asteroid belt.
It's a lot warmer than the other
bodies that I've been talking about.
It's a lot closer in.
So it's a water rich asteroid.
It's the largest asteroid
in the asteroid belt.
And like I was saying it's a
little bit further in then some
of the bodies we've
been talking about.
You can tell because it has a
pretty warm surface temperature
of negative 105 degrees
Celsius whereas Triton we start
out at negative 230.
And so it's closer in, if
we think about the order
of the planets from the sun outward.
We have Mercury, Venus,
Earth, then we have Mars,
then we have the asteroid belt.
That's where we find Ceres and
everything else is farther out.
So Ceres is pretty cool.
It has this interesting, if you
look at this picture on the bottom,
it has this interesting
internal structure.
It has a rocky core from
inside out, a rocky core.
Then there's a water ice layer.
And then there's this
thin dusty crust.
And there's lots of clays and things
like brucite on the
surface of Ceres.
And brucite is a mineral
that has the formula MG0H2
and that's basically Maalox.
That's basically Milk of Magnesia.
[laughter] So you have this nice
dusty Milk of Magnesia crust
on Ceres so it's pretty interesting.
And you notice that
there's a water ice layer.
And when we say that things in the
solar system have a water ice layer,
that's always kind of tricky because
that means that there's a chance
for there to be water and
ice but we're not sure
within that layer how much of it
is water and how much of it is ice.
So the thinking is that Ceres
may have a subsurface ocean,
which would be very cool if it does.
Dawn just reached Ceres
a couple of months ago.
I think right before New
Horizons reached Pluto.
So we're still learning more.
This is a new image up top of Ceres.
And something that's
interesting is that ESA,
which is the European Space Agency,
their Herschel Space Observatory
actually observed water vapor being
spewed out into space
from two spots on Ceres.
And this is just an
artist's conception.
This is not what they saw.
No one actually saw this.
And so they now believe that that
water vapor could have been due
to cryovolcanoes or geysers
just pumping water vapor out.
And so that's an exciting place.
We also see if we look
at the picture of Ceres,
this is a real picture of Ceres
up at the top to your left,
there are two bright spots, and I
don't know if everyone can see those
but those bright spots are either
thought to be salts or ices,
either way, two of the theories are
that they were brought up either
by actually icy volcanoes
or icy geysers.
So either way Ceres
is very interesting.
So we have, we talked about
this, and is it almost 12:00?
Ok so we talked about this
and so now let's get to Europa
which is the moon that I
did my dissertation on.
My favorite moon in
the outer solar system.
And you can see that Europa
has this opaque white surface
and that's the ice.
And then you have these
reddish brown regions
which we believe are salts.
You have lots of these
lines across the surface.
And those lines, singular
for those lines is linear,
plural for those lines is linea.
So there's a certain conference
that I go to and whenever I talk
about Europa someone always
tweets her name is Lynnae
and she's talking about Europa.
There are lots of linea.
[laughter] What a fitting name.
So it's just, maybe I was born
to study Europa, who knows?
So let's talk about
Europa from the inside out.
You have a small iron core.
You have a rocky layer
or a rocky mantle.
And then you have a water ice
shell but remember what I told you
about water ice shells, some
part is ice, some part is water.
We're never 100 percent
sure which part is which.
We can tell by looking at
pictures of Europa that the outside
of it is ice, that makes
sense, the crust is ice
because ice is less
dense than water.
We know that ice cubes
float in water
so that makes sense the
ice would be at the top.
Below it we believe
that from measurements
by the Galileo Spacecraft
that there are,
there's an extensive
ocean beneath it.
And so this water ice
layer is between 100
and 150 kilometers thick.
And so we think that the ice
layer at most is maybe, you know,
somewhere between 20
to 40 kilometers thick
so that's a lot of water.
Europa actually has twice the
amount of water that the earth has.
And if you look at this image
of at the bottom of earth
and then our moon and Europa, you
see how much smaller Europa is
than earth so to have that
much water is just astounding.
And so one thing that's
interesting about Europa is it's
about 90 percent ice
and 10 percent rock.
We call it icy satellite but really
it's mostly rocky and that's part
of the reason it has some
of these dynamic processes
that are so interesting.
One of my Professors at
Johns Hopkins used to joke
that Europa was really,
and 90 percent rock,
was really a rocky body just
masquerading as an icy body.
But why do we call it an icy body?
Because all the geophysical
processes and geological processes
that we can see actually
occur in ice.
And so it's a little bit
smaller than our moon.
See the radius is about
50 to 60 kilometers.
Our own moon the radius
is about 1,738 kilometers.
And the surface is a chilly
negative 173 degrees Celsius.
You've seen these reddish
brown marks on the surface.
A lot of that comes from some
of these surface species.
We see Carbon Dioxide, Carbon
Monoxide on the surface.
We see Sodium Chloride, which
that's regular old table salt,
magnesium sulfate,
just a sulfate salt.
And also sulfuric acid hydrates.
One thing that's really
interesting about Europa is
that it may be the only other
body in the solar system,
in addition to earth,
to have plate tectonics.
So these other solar system bodies
I've been showing you, they have,
you know, they have tectonics.
You have the crust moving.
But when it moves everything
just, it moves as one continuous,
you know, one continuous crust.
Everything linked together.
Europa may be broken up into plates.
And so it's a really exciting place.
So let's talk about its
place in the Jupiter system.
And we have Europa here,
you can see the second moon
with its sister satellites
Io, Ganymede and Callisto.
Io, these are the four Galilean
satellites so named because Galileo,
Galileo discovered them when
he trained his telescope
on them such a long time ago.
And so Io is the most volcanically
active body in the solar system.
There are volcanoes
going off everywhere.
Ganymede is the largest moon in the
solar system and it's the only moon
in the solar system to
have its own magnetic field
like earth has its
own magnetic field.
And then Callisto is a little
bit smaller than Ganymede.
It has a pot marked surface.
Those are caused by
impacts by asteroids
and comets and things like that.
And so we have on the bottom this
title energy and we see that it's,
title energy, you have quite a
lot of it when you're near Io.
As you go out to Callisto
it pretty much diminishes.
So what is tidal energy
or what is tidal heating?
So tidal energy, or tidal
heating as I like to call it,
is just what happens to these
moons as they're orbiting Jupiter.
They're much smaller than
Jupiter, much, much smaller.
Jupiter is huge compared to
earth so it's much, much,
it's gargantuan compared
to these moons.
And so as these moons are moving
in their orbits around Jupiter,
different parts of them are
pushed and pulled and tugged
at different times and
that creates friction.
That friction that's caused
by that pushing and pulling,
it's just like if you rubbed
your hands past each other,
you start doing that and you keep
doing it, your hands get warm.
So that friction causes,
that friction from Jupiter,
causes the innards of these
bodies to be heated quite a bit.
Io gets the most heat because
it's closest to Jupiter.
Because it gets the most heat,
volcanism is the geological process
that dominates that surface.
Skip over Europa but as we
get to Ganymede you have,
you still have title energy,
not nearly as much as at Io
but you still have some and so
tectonics, movements in the crust
in the lithosphere are what really
affect the surface of Ganymede.
By the time you get to
Callisto, poor Callisto,
there's really no tidal
energy for Callisto.
And so we don't expect
Callisto to be dynamic world.
We're looking at it, it has
all these impact craters.
If there were things
upwelling from the subsurface
such as cryolavas it
would kind of smooth
out that surface and
we don't see that.
And so Europa's in an interesting
place if we look at Europa.
So Europa gets not as much tidal
energy as Io but more than Ganymede
and so it's in a regime where
not only can you have tectonics
but you can have volcanism
so this is an exciting thing.
And if we talk about Europa's
place in the Jupiter system, again,
I have just two movies,
if they will work.
They worked before.
Let's try to get out
of this and see.
Ok so this first movie just shows
Europa orbiting along with Ganymede
and Callisto, I'm sorry Europa
orbiting with Ganymede and Io.
And Europa, Ganymede and
Io are in a residence.
And just in simple terms that means
that for every four
times Io orbits Jupiter,
Europa orbits twice,
Ganymede orbits once.
And it's kind of difficult to see
here but this is what this image,
this animation, is
supposed to be showing.
And so because Europa is in this
kind of residence with Ganymede
and with Io, it's also pushed and
pulled and tugged in its orbit
with Ganymede and Io and that adds
additional heat to its interior.
And this second movie just
shows what I'm talking
about when I say it's pushed
and pulled and different parts
of it are elongated and shortened
in its orbit around Jupiter.
So that's great.
So we talked about, give me
one second here, ok, so great.
And it put me back at
the beginning of my talk.
How great is that?
We'll get there.
Ok and this is right
where I need to be.
So we've talked about the difference
between volcanism and cryovolcanism.
We talked about where
we see cryovolcanism.
We talked about Europa.
Is there evidence for
cryovolcanism on Europa?
And the answer is yes there is.
The Galileo Spacecraft sent
us back lots of nice images.
We got a lot of these images back in
the late 90's, you know, into 2000.
And we see at the top left
you see a pond like feature.
It does not look like the
surrounding planes in the back.
And so it looks like a pond
therefore Planetary Scientists,
we call that the pond.
And it is a smooth feature and it
looks like you've had some sort
of runny fluid that's just
come up and erupted and flowed
onto the service just
in that circular area.
And then to the right of that
this mitten shaped feature.
Guess what we call that?
The mitten.
[laughter] And so the
correct name is Murias Chaos
but most people call it the mitten.
And so the mitten basically just
looks like you've had this kind
of viscus sticky lava that
kind of erupted and came
out onto the surface and
kind of spread and kind
of up domed at the edges.
And we think that's
what happened there.
At the bottom you have
this darker spot on Europa,
Thrace Macula, to the bottom left.
And that's pretty cool.
It's much darker than
the surrounding terrain.
And then beside it
to the right of that
on the bottom we have
a close up of Thrace.
And you can see that although it
looks like the center has been baked
in place, if you look
at the edges there looks
like there's been some sort of
fluid that's just been moving
across the surface.
And so these were taking
with the evidence
of cryovolcanic flows
of lava flows here.
And so what about, so
these are the nice, quiet,
quiescent eruptions,
don't cause any trouble.
What about the explosive
cryovolcanism?
Yes, there is actually,
we have evidence for that.
So we have, this is a
double rich ridge here
and you see this arrow pointing
to these darker, this white arrow
at the top pointing
to these dark features
and here's a close up
of that to the right.
And it's believed that what
happened was there was an explosive
cryovolcanic eruption or
several along this double ridge.
And it threw up particles and
water vapor and they came back
to the ground and kind of lined
the surface along these ridges.
And then at the bottom you see a
picture where, at the bottom left
where you see these reddish
brown features, those are thought
to be salts that came up, could
have come up during an eruption
and this colored the surface.
Salts and CO2 and other
things like that.
And we see them surrounding
these freckles.
And you have the same thing
on the bottom right image.
And so, let's see if I can go
through this a little bit quicker.
So the interesting thing
with terrestrial volcanism
versus cryovolcanism is that
when we think of lavas moving
through earth's surface or up
through the surface of Venus
or what used to occur on the moon
millions and billions of years ago,
that these lavas as they
move up towards the surface,
this is a fresher diagram so going
to, pointing down to the interior
of the planet, pointing up is
to the surface, as these lavas
or these magmas, excuse me,
as they are in the subsurface,
move up to the surface.
They tend to want to superheat.
So they stay in very warm.
They erupt.
And the issue with cryolavas
is if you have a watery fluid
or even a watery fluid that
may not even be pure water
but just has a little
bit of salt in it,
as it moves to the
surface it's going to want
to freeze and that's an issue.
So how do you solve that issue?
Well you can actually solve
that issue by adding salt.
Adding salt to some of these fluids
will help them want to super heat
and remain warm as they
get to the surface.
And that's really good for the case
of Europa because we see evidence
of salts on the surface
in areas where we believe
that the surface has been
in contact with some sort
of subsurface fluid reservoir.
And so I will, this is just a table
showing plausible compositions
of icy lavas.
You can see that a lot of these,
these are just sodium sulfate salts.
If you look at hydrohalite which
is down kind of in the middle,
that's sodium chloride, that 2H2O,
that's just hydrated table salt
that could be erupting
onto the surface of Europa.
And we will skip that one.
And so this has been pretty great.
So we talked about cryovolcanism,
what can we model on Europa?
So we believe that there's
cryovolcanism on Europa.
We have imagery that
suggests that that is true.
And so if that is the case,
remember I talked to you
about what we thought was an
icy volcanic dome on the surface
of Titan, it ended up not being one.
We also see things that look like
icy volcanic domes on the surface
of Europa and the question is
what would be the necessary lava
viscosity and composition
to form these domes?
And you can see at the top here
we have two domes we believe are
cryovolcanic in origin, again
from cryolavas coming out,
erupting onto the surface and
then kind of, they're very viscus
so they're spreading kind
of like a dome shape.
And so we've looked
at, what I've done
with my colleagues is applied
some analytical models to see
if we can kind of model the
formation of these domes.
And so here in this next image
you just see several more domes
that could, we believe,
have been formed as a result
of viscus cryolavas
coming onto the surface.
And so these domes have heights
between 40 and 100 meters.
They're 3 - 10 kilometers
in diameter.
The size of these domes they're
intermediate size between domes
on earth and in Venus but they are
thought to have formed the same way
through just having
very sticky viscus lava.
And their formation
was modeled actually
in 2003 initially using models that
had been applied to domes on earth
and Venus by Sarah Fagents
at the University of Hawaii.
We got Sarah on our team and said
can we make these models a little
bit more accurate?
So I'm about to show you a
slide that's a little scary
because there are two
equations and a lot of words.
And I won't go through these
equations just to say that the one
at the top is a differential
equation
that describes the process
that we're looking at.
H is going to be the
height of the dome.
You see that at the
top of the numerator.
If any of you are students
of physics,
math or engineering you're used
to seeing differential
equations so that's wonderful.
We have a nice differential
equation.
The equation right below
that is the solution
to this differential equation and
using this equation and putting
in certain parameters for
viscosity of a cryolava,
if we put in parameters for
that tells us something
about the composition
or we can infer something
about the composition.
So this equation gives us height
of the dome after it's erupted
onto the surface, height of the
dome as a function of its distance
from the central vent where it
initially erupted from and time.
And what can we do?
Can we get profiles?
We absolutely can from
this equation.
And these profiles are
symmetric so if we had,
if we extended this graph we'd
see the exact same four profiles,
exact same heights in places, on the
left side as we see on the right.
So basically these
are four profiles.
We've looked at these domes and
looked at a certain viscosity.
And this shows, in the red,
that after three years this final
profile, basically we tracked
after this cryolava has
erupted, how it moves and spreads
across the surface and
what the final profile is.
We see the final profile after
three years is pretty similar
to the profiles of these domes
that I showed you on this image.
So the final profile is
about 80 meters high,
about 2 1/2 kilometers in radius.
That's great.
We love math.
We can do math, that's great.
But what does that say
about planetary science?
How does this final profile in
the red after three years stack
up against topography that we
got from the Galileo mission?
Well it's consistent with the
topography but not a perfect match
and that's why we call it science.
And so if you look at this
red box here we've taken,
I've taken that red box
and kind of these kind
of turquoise diamonds are the
topography from this dome.
And so the models are consistent
with topography from Europa
that we know from the
Galileo Spacecraft
but we could always do a lot better.
And so that's great.
We're going to keep doing that.
I just received funding to
keep modeling these domes
and see what their
compositions might be,
what their viscosity's might
be, that could tell us a lot
about the subsurface structure
of Europa, about cryomagma bodies
in the subsurface and how
they move to the surface.
That's very exciting.
And so there are a lot of words
on this slide but I will skip
to the final bullet and say
that when you do theory,
which is using math to figure
out things in planetary science,
you always want to be able to match
that to actually observed data.
The model is no good if
you look at something
on Europa and the two don't match.
You could be making up
anything and nobody is going
to trust it as well, they shouldn't.
And so we need better
imagery of Europa.
Higher spatial resolutions images
so higher resolution images
so that we can get
better model constraints.
And the bad news is
I will not get that,
that will not happen any time soon
but the good news is it will happen
in 10 to 15 years so NASA
has a mission to Europa
that I'm very excited about.
And there is, I'm actually
on the Science team.
I'm on the camera team.
We'll make this nice camera.
We'll be able to see domes and other
images on Europa in this camera.
The principle investigator is
Dr. Elizabeth Turla [phonetic]
at the Johns Hopkins University
Applied Physics Laboratory
and so I'm very excited about that.
It's very nice how many people
will get to do their thesis
on the moon they love and
then turn around and get to be
on a space flight mission.
So it's wonderful.
So if we can get this next video to
play, I may have to get out of this.
And they are going
to talk about Europa.
Here's just a very short
video and you're going
to see Dr. Bob Pappalardo from
NASA's Jet Propulsion Laboratory's,
the project scientists
on the mission.
You'll see Dr. Claudia
Alexander who did a lot
of work on the Galileo Mission.
Unfortunately we lost her
just a couple of months ago
but they're going to talk
about why Europa is exciting.
>> Europa is the most likely.
>> Lynnae Quick: Uh
oh [Background Music]
>> Europa is the most
likely place to find life
in our solar system today because we
think there's a liquid water ocean
beneath its surface.
Now we know that on earth everywhere
that there's water, we find life.
So could Europa have the
ingredients to support life?
>> We might be actually looking
at a body that is presently alive,
presently active and presently
undergoing its geology.
There is too much evidence right
now lying around on the surface,
the red stuff, that suggests
that something is going on there.
Is that an environment that is
habitable for any sort of life form?
By golly we really have got to
go back and figure that out.
[ Music ]
>> We have designed a Europa mission
to take a spacecraft and a set
of instruments all the way
from planet earth to Jupiter.
>> Previous mission concepts were
for spacecraft that
would orbit Europa.
But Europa is bathed in
radiation from Jupiter.
Any mission that goes
in the vicinity
of Europa is cooked pretty quickly.
Instead we are looking at a
mission that will orbit Jupiter,
make close fly byes
of Europa and then zip
out of the high radiation region.
>> Kind of like when I was
a kid we had the sprinklers
and we didn't want to be too
close to the sprinkler head
so we would run in and get a little
water and then run back out again.
>> This allows us to have a
mission that's many years long
and to collect and transmit
lots and lots of data.
As Europa orbits Jupiter it flexes
and we could measure the
gravitational change of Europa
by encountering Europa at
different points in its orbit.
On a typical fly bye we would turn
on our remote sensing instruments,
we would image the surface, we
would interrogate the surface
with spectroscopy and we would
do the same thing on the way out
and we would essentially rinse
and repeat and do this many,
many times until we
understand Europa globally.
Images from the Hubble
Space Telescope tells us
that Europa might be erupting
plumes of water, high into space.
If that's true then we could
fly through those plumes
with a spacecraft and
literally taste it
to understand the composition
of Europa's interior.
>> If it does have the
ability to harbor life,
how does that work exactly?
We'll have enough instrumentation
to really pinpoint exactly
how the mechanisms would work
for replenishing the nutrients
into a subsurface ocean.
>> Europa is so important
because we want to understand,
are we alone in the cosmos?
If there is life in Europa it almost
certainly was completely independent
from the origin of life on earth.
That would mean the origin
of life must be pretty easy
throughout the galaxy and beyond.
[ Music ]
>> Lynnae Quick: And so sorry
that sound was not very good
on that but it's very exciting.
They showed these images of
plumes that it would be great
if a spacecraft could fly through.
Plume is just another way of
saying cryovolcanic geysers.
So it's very exciting.
And then Dr. Pappalardo mentioned
that the Hubble Space Telescope
believes that it saw plumes erupting
from Europa about, I believe maybe
it was last year a paper came
out and we were so excited.
And so the one thing that, if
I could just the last slide,
the one thing that I was hoping
that you all would take away
and did it take me
back to the beginning?
It does. How wonderful.
And then will not let me scroll.
Ok so before we, so the one thing
that I want you to take away is
that icy moons are important.
Icy bodies are important.
You have lots of water
on these icy bodies.
As they orbit, their planets,
like you have Jupiter
imparting lots of heat.
The interesting thing
about a moon like Europa is
that you have an ocean that's
up against the rocky mantel
or up against the rocky layer.
That's exactly what we have on
earth when we have the sea floor.
At our sea floor we
have hydrothermal vents,
we have different habitats for
life, lots of interesting things.
So when we think about these moons,
these moons are really what we
call astrobiologically important.
They have water.
They have heat.
There are nutrients that are needed
for life that could be cycled.
Anytime you have those three
things that's always exciting
and that's one of the reasons for
the Europa mission so I thank you
so much for bearing with me.
I will take questions if anyone has
them or comments whether they have
to do with science or me being a
scientist or I saw your hand first.
No, there is no possibility
of the moon collapsing.
That stuff that's going out
into space is coming from areas
on the south pole of Enceladus.
Enceladus is a round body because
we have something called hydrostatic
pressure that works with gravity
to keep everything clumped
together and strong.
When something is circularized
it probably will not collapse.
So if you were to think about
an asteroid that was maybe
like a rubble pile
where everything wasn't,
you know, it wouldn't be circular.
It wouldn't be spherical.
It would be some strange shape.
Then you may have to worry
about losing too much to space
but that's not going to
happen with Enceladus.
Just next, right and
so the question was
in my opinion what would be a
good place to prospect elements
and nutrients, is that
what you were saying?
>> Mining would be economically
important to the earth.
>> Lynnae Quick: Economically
Well I will say with a
caveat that I love Europa
but the ice shell is
30 kilometers thick.
So there would be lots of good
nutrients there and lots of things
that you could learn and
you always have students
in astrobiology courses that
want to do a term project
and see what it would take
to drill through the ice.
That's 30 kilometers worth of ice.
That's not going to happen.
I believe that if we look at earth's
own moon though there are lots
of resources that could be
mined and could be drilled.
We think there could be a
water cycle on the moon,
which we did not know
before, on earth's moon.
And a lunar reconnaissance
orbiter, LRO, is looking at the moon
and orbiting it and taking
pictures and taking data.
And you always, at these LRO
meetings you have several people
who actually talk about mining
our own moon for resources.
So that would be great.
That is someplace that's
near to us and someplace
that we could easily
place people again.
And as generations go and we
get further into technology
and time passes, then
maybe we could have a drill
that was big enough
to get to Europa.
I think the first part for Europa
though was actually sending a
spacecraft there.
That's the first step.
The first thing we want to do.
And, yes, that's a
very good question.
So the question was
how do atmospheres
and planets affect the expression
of cryovolcanism on
some of these moons?
And so it affect it quite a lot.
So the smaller the body is,
the smaller the gravity is.
And when you have these
geyser like eruptions,
the farther the particles
can go up into space,
which is why Enceladus actually
feeds one of Saturn's rings water
because it's so small and easy
for those particles to escape.
For Europa, Europa is much
bigger than Enceladus.
Europa is a little bit
smaller than our own moon.
So you probably would not
have geysers that are able
to erupt particles as high
because gravity is just
going to pull it back down.
For the question about atmospheres,
remember I mentioned Neptune's
moon Triton which is the only moon
in our solar system with
an appreciable atmosphere.
And it's a thick atmosphere.
It's thick and cold and
it's almost as thick as,
if anyone knows anything
about Venus,
Venus has an atmosphere that's
comparable except for Venus is
so hot and it's in the
inner solar system.
So the atmospheric pressure is so
high but you're not really going to,
you don't think you're going to
see geysers on a moon like that.
You are going to see just lavas
that are flowing out quietly
and quiescently and they're probably
going to be very, very viscus
but that's a good question,
very good question.
Yes, right, ok, so the question
is do I know how deep the ocean is
on Europa, is that
what you're asking?
So we know that the water
and ice layer together is
between 100 and 150 kilometers.
We think the ice is about
30 kilometers thick.
So that leaves anywhere
between 70 to 120 kilometers
so that's a lot of water.
>> Any theory on how that
could have developed,
how you get a ball of water?
>> Lynnae Quick: Well initially, if
I give the theory we'll have to talk
about planet formation a little bit.
So I will say that initially
what we believe happened is
that you have this body and it was
probably maybe a little bit warmer
and at some point as time
passes it lost more heat
because these bodies
start out a little warm.
You had it begin to
freeze from the top down.
And so that's what
creates the ice crust.
We think like earth, when we think
about why we have water on earth,
we believe that we had a
lot of volatile and water
and light species delivery
from comets.
So initially how it
probably got there was
that you had very hydrous
water rich bodies that kind
of clumped together to make Europa.
Did that answer your question?
[inaudible audience question] Our
ocean is just a sliver, right.
Because Europa is in
a, as you move out,
further out into the solar
system it's easier for there
to be light molecules like water
and volatiles and things like that.
As you move in closer
to the sun it's hotter.
And so it's really nice
that we have water.
You look at poor Mercury and Venice
and I mean they're really steamy.
So we're kind of right
in the right place,
what we call the Goldilocks
zone, not too hot, not too cold.
But as you move further
out for different reasons,
we can talk about a
little bit more offline,
you are able to have more water as
you move farther and farther away
from the sun and it's able
to you know just stay there
and not evaporate away.
So there was a question
here and then one over here.
Yes sir? Ok so the question was
would cryovolcanism exhibit any
phreatic eruptions or marked
craters and would it be different?
So the phreatic eruptions, those are
the more violent eruptions, correct.
>> Well basically not about earth
but just underneath the surface
that causes basically a crater.
Like you've seen craters in
Death Valley have no life.
>> Lynnae Quick: My
feeling is that it could.
If we're talking about craters
that are just beneath the surface
you would need very high resolution
images to see that.
And I will say too
that we're talking
about cryovolcanism although
I'm very, very excited about it,
keep in mind that our first look
at cryovolcanism was
in 1989 with Voyager 2.
And if we want to put that
into perspective that was
when I was five years old.
And for science that is
yesterday, that's just yesterday.
So it's an emerging field.
And I would say that
that is possible.
I would have to think about
the physical processes
and what would be needed as far
as composition and maybe thickness
of a, regional thickness
or thinness of a crust
that would allow that to happen.
Of course, ok, yes?
>> Jennifer Harbster:
Probably one more.
>> Lynnae Quick: Ok yes sir?
Ok so the question was when
we think about volcanoes
on earth they're a
little bit more circular
and I showed an image
earlier where I said
that you probably had
cryovolcanism along a linear feature
and what's the deal with that?
And so keep in mind when we
think about volcanoes on earth
and volcanism there
are different types.
So we see these nice cinder
cones but we also see,
if you remember from, let's see,
one of the first slides, exactly,
the fissure eruption which is
to your left, the bottom left,
where you have lava erupting from
what looks like a line source.
So we believe that we definitely
see the same things on earth
that we're saying could
be happening on Europa.
So it's still a volcanic eruption
when you see a fissure eruption.
It's not as crazy out
there as it seems.
Now in finding that picture I
may have forgotten a little bit
of your question and gotten
off but did I answer that?
Ok, alright, that's it.
Thank you so much.
[applause]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.